[Music]
so I recently received a couple of pair
of the are for revision for pixel whips
by fiber flies and I also happened to
have a copy of alien John currently he's
now the brains behind fiber flies I've
been the brains of pixel whip in general
or pixel what we just called them fiber
flies v1 the
so on and so forth and then I
I mean I essentially taught myself CAD
modeling in order to more closely work
with my manufacturer I've added this
nice padded rubber grip so that if your
hands are getting sweaty or something
like that you've got more grip and
perhaps more importantly because
a lot of us now experimenting with
some rope dart or poi spinning like
the new bird it's now safer for your
head I've only got one microphone so if
I'm ever going like this is because I'm
trying to keep John's voice voice on the
mic they take this big rechargeable
battery yes it should last like five to
eight hours on a full charge depending
on what color mode here you think and
they ship now with a USB charger yes
I've known John for years if I haven't
mentioned so this is all his all of us
has happened in the time I've known him
I'm really proud of him for making all
this happen there are now 40 different
patterns on here arranged into four
different color styles so that's ten
patterns per color style basically so
for instance here let's let me switch us
back to the beginning so here we are on
just like a solid color it's simple and
nice and I can click through the
different colors the rainbow there's a
ton of those click just goes to the next
color
quick click taking me through the colors
over and over again but let's say I'm
bored of cell color and I want something
a little different so if I long press
for a second until I see it blink and
then I let go when it blinks Boop that
just changed us to this base now there
are 10 of these and I can quit click
through to my heart's content picking
different crossfade modes until I find
what I like but maybe I get kind of
tired of that and I want a long press
and get to the third style which is a
three colors two mothers three color
streaks so
maybe hopefully the camera is picking it
up nicely I now have ten different kind
of Rasta color like more earth or water
colors there's a lot there's a lot more
different three color kind of moods to
choose from and then my personal
favorite style mode or style for is the
strobing one where I instead of just the
the rainbow unicorn crazy strobe that
everybody loved there's that and nine
other different color swatch strobing
high melting fun colors and so the nice
thing about how this works is from slot
1 through 10 it's remembering where I am
so if I'm on let's say slot 3 which
happens to be this kind of fiery color
and I change styles instead of just quit
clicking oh look it's it's yellow in the
first style which is kind of related and
then if I change again oh look that that
also is a similar related color scheme
and now you know here's here's the red
yellow white three color and then that
becomes the strobe
so there's across the Styles there's a
color cohesion when you change them or
you can quit click to change and find
your different color combinations and
then style change through that so it's
kind of like no matter whether you're
cooking quickly or long pressing this
thing change styles it's always gonna
feel like a something new but a cohesive
change I'm gonna do a quick spin with
two
we even do like you knew
Hyperloop
writing that paper live
very cool and you'll be probably seeing
I've started in some photography with
these and I'm hoping there's a lot more
photography coming because they just
look really juicy in photos you know our
four picture lips took it up for your
first purchase with my website nick has
an incentive code that will save you
some money yeah there we go
watermelon color
[Music]